and i am laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight
stolen futures that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now the evidence is mounting and the
facts are they're just too devastating
to ignore
tonight the angle will conclusively
demonstrate that democrats aren't just
destroying our economy and our foreign
policy
they're also destroying something even
more precious
our children
they're destroying their innocence their
education
their spirit their sense of optimism
they're destroying their future
now look no further than liberal
montgomery county maryland it's a
wealthy suburb of washington d.c
where we see the shocking consequences
of majority liberal democrat rule
now during the pandemic we spent a great
deal of time exposing the county
executive there an uber liberal named
mark elrich
now long after we knew that coveted
lockdowns and rules were hurting our
kids badly
the man refused to budge
in our opinion the best solution is to
do a temporary pause the school system
needs to take a pause
and
and then the chaos it's way too chaotic
right now
it was vindictive and now the results
are in
academically montgomery county students
are falling further and further behind
now data shows that in 2019 it's not a
great figure but just over 50 percent of
public school students there
demonstrated proficiency in the english
language arts but then go to 2021 that
figure dropped to
36 percent
and it's not just the democrats covered
closures they robbed the kids of class
time of sports of socialization
they also triggered an explosion of
crime
well idle hands are the devil's
playground indeed
police in montgomery county say they're
seeing unprecedented levels of violent
crime
as of the end of june homicides
involving guns victims and suspects
under the age of 21 have more than
doubled from 2021 to 2022.
and we can all see it right i mean we
see the anger the fury the callousness
manifests in the horrific crimes now
being committed by young people across
america
in philly two brothers aged 10 and 14
just turned themselves into police over
the beating death of a 73 year old man
the video
it's stomach churning you can see the
group of teens hitting him over and over
again with a traffic cone now this
happened around 2 30 in the morning
so why the heck are kids this age out in
the middle of the night where the heck
are the parents
now the stories over just the past week
are equally disturbing
in new york city a year old was arrested
in the stabbing death of a 14 year old
in the subway
in mississippi teen brothers were
arrested for shooting and killing a 17
year old
while a 19 year old there was arrested
for the murder of his six-year-old
half-brother
then over in detroit a 13-year-old was
charged in the murder
of his 14-year-old girlfriend
there's a growing sense among young
people that
look they can commit crimes even murder
with zero consequences
and as a result more retail outlets are
now leaving big cities altogether forget
it not gonna be there anymore
after rampant robberies and shootings
even 711 is encouraging franchise owners
to close stores across los angeles today
and starbucks they're closing 16
locations across five major cities
citing safety concerns
oh can you blame them
who would want to open a business today
in chicago
st louis baltimore san francisco why was
capital there when you could open up in
safer places where criminals are
actually punished that's a novel concept
so congrats democrats because you excuse
and you justify crime you look the other
way and you end up hurting the
hard-working people who actually keep
these cities running
now back in the spring of 2020
we tried desperately i don't know how
many nights the angle tried to warn the
blue state leaders that if they kept
their towns their cities their states
their schools locked down
they'd shatter not just their economy
but their children
get all the lockdown governors you know
who they are gavin newsom gretchen
whitmer jb pritzker andrew cuomo wolf in
pennsylvania they didn't care
because for them it was all about
control and power
hey children had to suffer as a result
well too bad
because the teachers unions ran the show
and they ran our kids into the ground
now of course they're back in school now
but it doesn't mean they're going to
actually be given a quality education
we know what the far left nut jobs in
the nea really want
we will fight
tirelessly
for the right to choose
we will never stop
we will say gay
we will save trans
we will continue
to take seriously
our responsibility as educators to teach
our students this nation's true
and complete
history
you get in the way of our progress
toward a more just nation we will get in
the way of your election
okay these aren't educators
they're mercedes marxists
they're ignorant blowhards
they're not teaching your kids how to
read and how to write how to think
critically they're teaching them how to
protest
and agitate against their own country
and when you know we know where they get
their cues
because when young people were ripping
down statues and taking over city blocks
in the name of racial reckoning they
were celebrated and given their marching
orders this is a movement i'm telling
you they're not going to stop and and
everyone beware because they're not
going to stop they're not going to let
up and they should not and we should not
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there's unrest in our
lives we got to stay on the street uh
and we've got to get more active we've
got to get more confrontation we've got
to make sure that they they know that we
need business
well we know exactly what you mean
maxine
you hope that if you stoke enough anger
in young people toward police or toward
the government or the constitution they
won't even notice what an utter fraud
and failure you've been during your 30
years in politics
so democrats not only stole precious
class time
athletics socialization from our kids in
some cases they actually stole their
ambition as well
because since the school closures
chronic absenteeism has exploded for
both students and teachers
just in the 2021-2022 school year 49
percent of schools reported higher
chronic absenteeism that's more than 10
absent absence for teachers and a
ridiculous high 39 percent for students
now this is disturbing but the democrats
don't seem to realize that when their
policies directly harm children
they've effectively declared war on the
parents as well
the relentless promotion of things like
transgenderism pot porn abortion and of
course racial grievance the attacks on
the great works of western civilization
tax on our founding and our constitution
it just created this big negative swirl
among young people of cynicism and a
seething anger
today they're more depressed they're
more anxious
and they're less hopeful
according to a new survey done for
fortune magazine just came out 60 of
college kids reported being diagnosed
with a mental health condition and
almost half of all college students said
the pandemic worsened their mental state
young americans they need responsible
adults in charge
who will tell them the hard truths when
they're necessary
but with democrats running our schools
public health sector congress and the
white house our youth have been fed
nothing but lies and half truths
the democrats know they're in trouble
so they're blaming biden they blame the
messaging they blame the american people
but here's the harsh truth every day
more and more americans learn that
electing democrats leads to poverty
crime and despair
and it ruins the lives of our youngest
our most vulnerable citizens
american parents are on the move
and democrats are going to feel their
wrath at the polls
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else